now the important thing and maybe you
want to underline this right is this
height business it must be perpendicular
it must be perpendicular to the cross
section because it's easy to pick just
so we just discussed it's easy to pick
the wrong number okay if you pick the
right number right what you're doing is
no longer thinking of this as a prison
right so I've cut it in this way and get
the same here i'm going to do now you're
going to get the same cross-section
every time right but obviously this is
not the only way that i can cut up
where's my attachment I don't know it's
not the only way I can cut the shape
right who said I had to cut it this way
i can cut it in other ways right for
instance I could cut it up your space
yeah so I've got this kind of it's still
the same shame so the same shape still
has the same volume okay but I don't
want to cut it like this right I want to
avoid doing this why why is this like a
hickey wavelet very good so I've got
excuse me this guy which is a rectangle
this these also rectangles but term
excuse me they're different rectangles
and since I don't work out everyone
individually in this one it's not too
bad because I've only got three of them
but what if it's like a big issue and
I'm trying to work out like the exact
volume not like an approximate thing
okay so we don't want to do this we
always want to get the perpendicular
height okay now what's lovely about
business is why the heading was prison
right is you can have a prison which has
a square on the edge or a saurus sorry
not a circle a rectangle or any shape
you like you don't even need to have a
name for the shape right like so long as
it's consistent all the way along you
cut it the same thing you can have a
dinosaur prism right and you take or a
llama or a giraffe or a camel none needs
a home doesn't it and you can say it
look if you tell me what this
cross-sectional area is in fact no drug
can we draw this shape I'm just put it
here you can see it
okay draw the shape for me just as it is
with all of its square bits and all that
kind of thing okay I need some special
so our I'm dinosaur prism heated right
it looks something like this visual arts
in school okay there we go that is kind
of what I look here right now what is
that shape clearly I don't have a like
oh yes right along with my rectangle and
triangle and trapezium formula dinosaur
formula okay you don't have a formula
for that shape but that doesn't matter
so long as we know what the cross
sectional area is I can still use this
same approach I can still say the volume
use the cross-sectional area times the
perpendicular height so they will if
they give you a shape like this which is
a like a regular and weird they'll just
tell you what the cross section is so
for instance suppose this one's one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
that's convenient I'm going to say this
cross-sectional area is say ten square
centimeters right what is the
perpendicular height looks to me like
six right kind of right so therefore i'm
going to put over here now hi these six
centimeters ok so my dinosaur prism it
doesn't matter how read it is I've got a
cross-section I've got a height that's
perpendicular to that cross section if
you like think about to try and make
sure you pick the right leg cramp think
about the cross section where it is and
put it on the ground now it's the base
right and then the height is what you
normally think of as height it's just
gone straight up so when I came with on
this right where's the cross section
it's triangle x okay so put them on the
ground and look there's the hype right
so you can think of it in the dorm or
invention so what's the valley of this
thing it's going to be the cross
sectional area times the height which is
super easy right it's just going to be
yeah and don't forget these dudes okay
this is not complicated okay